Stand by.
We are now entering the
atmosphere of Venus.
Attention.
Before the first space programs
of the 20th century, it was thought
that our closest neighboring
planet may harbor life.
I can remember there are images
where there are dinosaurs
and flying dinosaurs.
Thick clouds covering the surface of Venus
caused humanity's imagination to run wild,
and for good reason.
So at first glance, Venus
and Earth are quite similar.
They are about the same size
and about the same mass.
And in fact, sometimes Venus
is called our sister planet.
But the first probes
set by the Soviet Union
and NASA discovered a world
plagued with a poisonous
greenhouse atmosphere,
a sweltering surface temperature
and a crushing air pressure.
The Venusian surface has a temperature
of over 450 degrees Celsius,
so lead essentially melts
on the surface of Venus.
It's very hostile.
And so attention turned
to our more hospitable neighbor, Mars,
leaving Venus largely
neglected for decades
but never forgotten.
Scientists long speculated
that microbial life could exist
in the permanent cloud-layer atmosphere.
It turns out that in the
upper layers of the atmosphere
between 50 to 60 kilometers
above the surface,
we found conditions which
are not that different
from the surface condition
we find on Earth.
Then in 2020, evidence of biomarkers,
potential signs of life, were
detected in that cloud layer.
It may be the case that
microbial life has adapted,
has evolved in order to survive
in the high clouds of Venus.
And although the claim was later disputed,
it reinvigorated an enthusiasm for Venus.
And scientists are
proposing multiple missions
with a single objective.
We can just pick one thing and go for it.
And we can also work on the taboo topic
of the search for life.
The Soviet Union's Venus missions
gave us the first landings
and images of the surface
of another planet,
the first audio recordings
from the surface
of another planet
and the first, and so far the only,
planetary balloon missions.
Balloons have already been flown
in the Venusian atmosphere,
the Vega I and II balloons.
So we know it works.
In 1985, the two spacecraft called Vega I
and Vega II arrived at Venus,
both equipped with landers
and balloons to explore
the cloud-layer atmosphere.
The balloons separated from the crafts
lasted more than 46 hours
while taking measurements.
The data from that upper
cloud layer differed greatly
from the hellish surface.
So the winds have speeds of
about 350 or 360 kilometers
per hour.
That's about the speed of a bullet train
and corresponds to the fastest
winds we have ever measured
on Earth.
If we only look at
temperature and pressure,
the conditions are very similar
to the surface conditions
on Earth.
However, the clouds, which on
Earth consist of water vapor,
they're actually made of sulfuric acid.
So we are looking for
life which can survive
in an extreme environment.
The cloud layer
is estimated to be 50 to 100 times drier
than the driest place on Earth,
the Atacama Desert in Chile.
Dr. Armando Azua-Bustos, an astrobiologist
and Atacama native has
spent much of his career
looking at whether life can
exist in extreme environments.
These organisms are called extremophiles,
life that is adapted to
survive in harsh environments,
like a desert with no known water source.
The near-sterile
environment of the Atacama
is normally used as a testing
bed for finding life on Mars.
But the clouds here could give us clues
about life on Venus too.
But the Venusian
atmosphere isn't just dry.
It's extremely acidic.
The Cave of the Lighted House in Mexico
contains toxic amounts of sulfuric acid.
Yet, microbial life has evolved
to use other chemical
processes to obtain energy
other than photosynthesis.
While we've been learning a lot
about extremophiles on Earth,
we've also continued to
learn more about Venus
since those early missions.
Now, in terms of knowledge of Venus,
today, we know much more about Venus
such as about the existing
of prebiotic components
such as ammonia and hydrogen cyanide.
We also know that the
greenhouse effect on Venus
started about 1 billion years ago.
So we know a lot more things about Venus
thanks to many missions
which went to Venus
such as orbital missions
in the past decades.
Very small amounts of oxygen
were detected in the atmosphere
by at least two different
separate independent probes.
And it's amazing because
we also don't know
how oxygen would be made on
Venus at the levels found.
And there's sort of enough puzzles
that something really interesting
is happening on Venus.
Recent probes to Venus
like the European Space
Agency's Venus Express
and the Japanese Aerospace
Exploration Agency's Akatsuki
has given us a lot of valuable science.
But only Mars has had missions
specifically looking
for organic compounds,
the ingredients for life.
Then in 2020, this happened.
It's an extraordinary possibility.
Living organisms floating in
the clouds of planet Venus.
There may be some form of life on Venus.
This gas is called phosphine.
Now, what exactly is it?
Do we have any idea?
A team led by astronomers in the U.K.
reported seeing the spectral
signature of phosphine
in telescope data.
Phosphine's very unusual because on Earth
it's only associated with life,
either bacteria in oxygen-free
environments like wetlands
or made by humans as
pesticides and other chemicals.
Suddenly, there was a
potential biomarker for life
in the Venusian atmosphere.
And this really changed
a little bit the picture
of astrobiology research
in our solar system.
While some groups have disputed the claim
saying that the phosphine
signal isn't there
or at least at levels less
than previously thought,
it's reinvigorated the interest
in Venus from the public
and scientific community.
So despite all this
controversy of phosphine,
people have started to
relook at the old so-called
legacy data from the
American and Russian probes
that went into the Venus
atmosphere in the late '70s
and early '80s.
And what's very intriguing is
it looks like there's evidence
for phosphine from that old data.
One thing everyone can agree on
is the need for more research into Venus.
NASA and the European Space
Agency recently green lit
three separate missions.
VERITAS will map the planet's
surface and DAVINCI+,
the second NASA mission, will
have an orbiter to image Venus
in the ultraviolet and infrared light,
and will send a probe
through Venus's atmosphere,
while the European Space Agency's Envision
will take high-resolution radar images
of the planet's surface.
Although these missions will
give us a lot of valuable data,
none of them are dedicated
solely to finding biomarkers.
In order to really determine
whether there is life,
we need to go there.
And for us, the question was immediately,
how can we quickly develop
and launch a mission
in order to determine
whether there's really life
in the Venusian atmosphere or not?
And within two weeks
after the announcement
of the potential discovery of phosphine,
we published a report
on this mission study
to deploy a fleet of balloons
in the Venusian atmosphere
and to search for life.
Balloons are used for scientific studies
on Earth due to their
cheap cost, simple design
and ability to stay in the atmosphere
for a long period of time.
You can buy high altitude balloons
for maybe a couple of
hundred dollars or euros.
They tend to be fairly robust
so you just launch them
and then you can essentially
forget about them.
And these are two benefits
which are also applicable
to the Venusian context.
And considering the
technology already exists,
it could be launched quickly.
Venusian balloon, which
consists essentially
of two basic elements,
so one is the balloon sphere
and then we have what we call a ChipSat.
So it's about the size of a credit card.
And we have a very small
payload such as a tiny camera
or small microscope on
board and all the subsystems
such as power supply and
communications, et cetera.
So far, this proposal hasn't made it
to the hardware phase yet,
but a separate study headed by
Professor Sara Seager at MIT
and funded in part by
Breakthrough Initiatives
is looking at three separate missions,
the first one to launch
via Rocket Lab's rocket
as early as 2023.
We're really, really, absolutely thrilled
that we have a mission to Venus.
We've partnered with Rocket
Lab to supply the scientist,
science team and science instrument.
And there's room for
like a tiny instrument,
less than 1 kilogram,
that will go on the probe,
and the probe is going to
drop through the atmosphere
very quickly.
So the probe would last maybe an hour.
And going through the cloud
layers that we care about,
that will be about three minutes.
So this mission is short,
and the instrument that the team chose,
it has a kind of complicated name.
It's called an
autofluorescing nephelometer.
Autofluorescence refers to the fact
that we're basically
shining ultraviolet light
on the droplets and looking
for any fluorescence
that, in other wavelengths,
other colors of light.
And then nephelometer is just
a fancy word for an instrument
that measures the light that's
scattered from particles.
If you have a black light,
and you're out in the desert
and you shine it on a scorpion,
the scorpion lights up green colored,
just like my piece of fluorescent plastic.
And that demonstrates how organic
compounds, life compounds,
could be found on Venus with fluorescence.
The instrument, which in its final form
will fit inside of an estimated
half-kilogram payload,
will be the first attempt on Venus
to specifically look for biomarkers.
This instrument by itself
is not going to be able
to definitively determine
that there's life on Venus.
But if we detect organic
compounds in the cloud droplets,
it's an indication that
there might be life.
If what they find looks promising,
their next mission would
be a balloon mission
to look for biomarkers in
different areas of the atmosphere.
We envision a balloon.
And we have a few very,
very specific things
we want to measure.
We'd like to remeasure the
gases that don't belong,
including phosphine
and ammonia and oxygen.
We'd like to check out these
droplets in more detail.
In particular, we want
to measure the acidity
of the droplets because there's
some new theories out there,
including one from my team,
that the droplets aren't all uniform
and that they're not
all incredibly acidic,
that some might be a more
friendly acidity to life.
And we'd also like to measure more details
about the composition of the droplets,
measure that directly, not
just from light scattering.
And if there are promising discoveries
from that mission, to ultimately
prove microbes are present,
they're proposing a third mission.
We would go to Venus with a balloon
and this balloon would
have a miniature rocket
attached to it.
And we would collect samples.
So we'd condense the cloud particles,
and we would trap some air
on Venus, some of the gases.
And we would package those,
get it inside the rocket,
which would launch from the balloon.
And it would intercept with an orbiter
that would then be able
to act as a cruise vehicle
to come home to Earth with
these precious samples,
so that here on Earth, we could
use our very sophisticated
and exquisite instruments
to look for life.
These missions
would be the first balloon missions
to look for life on another planet,
but probably not the last.
There are people who have been trying
to get a balloon mission to
Venus for decades actually.
It's not like we came and had
all these brilliant ideas.
We're obviously standing on the shoulders
of people before us, you know,
people who are still working
on such missions.
But with the rise of
private space companies
and the miniaturization of technology,
inexpensive balloon missions like these
could solve mysteries faster
and make space more accessible.
There's a basic human urge
to find out if we are alone,
but it's also of tremendous
importance if we think about
if we would find life on Venus,
did it have the same
origin as life on Earth
or did it really emerge in parallel?
And this has huge implications
also for us as humanity.
Every society in human history
appears to have had astronomy
as part of its culture.
And that is about wanting
to know and explore
what is beyond Earth.
And today that question,
you know, includes,
is there life out there?
I think it's part of wanting
to understand our place
in the universe.
Are we alone?
Are we unique?
Or is the universe filled
with other life forms?